here's your cut of the youtube money g
so how much did i really make in my
first month of youtube technically
making money on youtube for so long
deemed as an impossible thing to do or
not real money and i should just go off
to college and get a nice safe job yet
three weeks into this account and i'm
making more than any other job i could
get at 18 years old i know my mom's the
go i'm a nobody i should just give her
all the money well actually i am doing
that so wait until the end of the video
to see it but what people never thought
about was this was all calculated
see i know a lot of you guys don't know
me too well yet but the last few years
of my life have been spent fully
mastering the social media algorithms
and how to go viral i'm not as much of a
computer nerd sitting there decoding
chinese hacks like what people think i
mean when i say i understand the
algorithms rather i like to call myself
more of a psychologist because when i
say understand the algorithms what i
really understand is what people want to
see how to get people to stay
entertained and how to get them to even
click on my videos in the first place
and yes also the nerd part where i know
every setting tweak and trick to use on
the platform to boost my video
organically initially i started my tic
toc journey blowing up people's accounts
for cash and running accounts for
monthly pay but once i realized how
truly good of an understanding i have
for the algorithm i then took down 20
pages of notes on everything i know two
years later from that version of me just
starting my social media journey and
here i am with a professional camera on
my face looking up half of the sentences
i say two years later from
here i am with professional karen
pretty crazy though how nowadays you can
make a full living off being a content
creator this is the first time in
history where it's this easy to go viral
and making living off of it yet so many
people are afraid to even make their
first video i know not everyone wants to
be a content creator but even if you're
making a business or literally anything
just making content to go along with it
is just free advertising companies will
pay hundreds of thousands of dollars to
get their products across a few million
eyes yet you can do that completely for
free on tick tock now and basically
nobody's doing it whatever i can't
complain though if everybody was making
content who knows if my ass would have
the platform i have today so to start
this youtube journey obviously i had to
think of a way to go viral in the best
way possible so i thought of reacting to
tape videos with my mom and giving
trigger thumbnails i mean who wouldn't
want to watch that first video was doing
good at first we had 20 000 views in the
first 24 hours just from algorithm tips
i know then i got the idea to make my
videos go nuclear even more i went on an
alt account and tagged hundreds of tate
tick tock accounts saying check out
sunnyfest onyt he reacts to tate with
his mom a week later and i was sitting
pretty at just north of 10 million views
on tick tock all giving me free
publicity to my channel call it cheating
or whatever but i don't give a [ __ ] at
the end of the day you need to be as
creative as possible to get as many
views that's how the best marketers stay
on top remember all publicity is good
publicity even if you aren't getting
credit or they're not tagging you in
those videos each view like stacking a
brick on a house just continuously
building your empire here at about four
days into youtube and i hit the 4 000
hours watch time requirement for youtube
monetization which is actually pretty
insane because i hit that before i even
reach 1000 subs where it usually takes
people a couple of months to hit that
milestone finally youtube monetization
here's where the big bucks start rolling
in mom pack the bags we're moving to
florida we don't have to work again
well not that crazy quite yet it took
about five days before i actually got
approved for youtube monetization and
was able to start making cash off my
videos first day of monetization i made
a whopping 150 dollars from 70 000 views
of my videos honestly nothing too crazy
kind of a letdown so back to boston it
is florida's gonna have to wait next few
weeks i averaged about 150 to 300 per
day which isn't bad but i have high
goals for myself so that's really not
going to cut it i like to think of
youtube adsense as like fun bucks you
know nothing too special
but here's where the big bucks start
rolling in sponsorships i'm sure you're
thinking but i haven't seen any sponsors
in your videos how are you making money
and you're right i haven't had any
sponsors in my videos but first let me
show you these offers and then i'll get
back to why that is promotional agent 8k
for 30 to 60 second integration of my
video promo manager 1k for 60 seconds
promo manager 1k for 30 seconds
affiliate program for weeble 60 per
referral you get the idea so you're
probably asking yourself why aren't you
rolling in cash right now accepting all
those offers would be about 20 000 with
the amount you posted well there's a
pretty good reason at first from
building a brand it's important to keep
your name and reputation with your
audience high i'm launching my online
university next month to get [ __ ] done
university where i teach everything i
know about the social media algorithms
branding marketing business tips how to
monetize e-commerce i have gabe giro
making the fitness and lifting section
and much more a genuine passion project
in mind and there's already a large
stigma around online courses since
there's so many shitty people scamming
in the space so i decided not to accept
any brand deals and just try to maintain
my reputation squeaky clean that way i
have more trust with my viewers people
get to know me better and they'll see
that i'm actually providing a lot of
value in my university now you don't
need to stay like this forever not
accepting brand deals and promos once i
build up my brand and credibility more i
will start doing them to add another
revenue stream so how much did i really
make in my first month of youtube well
there's a few ways to calculate this
technically 2.5k from youtube adsense
but if you want to calculate what i
could have made about an extra 20k off
of sponsorships a few grand off
affiliate links and then growing my
social medias which raises my illiquid
net worth
so realistically clocking in at about 25
to 30k for my first month on youtube hey
not bad for a month into youtube on a
brand new account as a regular teenage
kid oh [ __ ] almost forgot gotta give my
mom some money
here's your cut of the youtube money g
i sent you a thousand on um then mo too
so it's about 2 000.
you're not paying me back mom this is
your cut of the deal
this is the youtube adsense yes i did i
made i made over two grand on youtube
adsense and that's your cut is the
youtube adsense are you [ __ ] filming
me in the bathroom get out of it no
you're not even gonna say thank you what
the [ __ ] is this i don't want to take
your money you're [ __ ] ridiculous
thanks for carrying the channel mom you
see when i promote making money and
having priorities on tick tock i'm not
saying work so much you hate your life
and make money just so you can buy
expensive cars and [ __ ] nah bro it's
about the freedom you do whatever you
want when you want plus you're able to
do things like give back to the people
you love which oh my god is the best
feeling in the world so guys if you are
interested in my knowledge of social
media marketing and business i would
definitely recommend checking out my
discord it's completely free and i have
a bunch more information and videos that
you can find i'm always there helping
out people answering questions all the
time it's a great place to just make
connections and ultimately get a good
start on your goals let me know what you
guys think of these style of videos try
to change it up remember to like
subscribe and join the discord of my
comments and i'll smell you in the next
vid